So Abby, fresh off the plane I hear.
Two weeks, actually.
Cheers!
Welcome to Japan!
Ethan?
The rent's paid off for the next six months.
You can stay, it's all right with me.
For Abby...
What should I do?
...what seemed like the bitter end...
I thought it was so brave coming to Tokyo,...
...but Ethan left me.
...was the beginning...
Ramen.
...of a new journey.
I wanna cook ramen.
I wanna make people happy the way you do.
Hi!
I will clean for you.
I'll clean the windows, the pots, the floors.
I'm training to become a ramen chef.
I think I know, let me try.
I did everything I saw you do.
There's something about the Japanese and making the perfect bowl of soup.
It's kind of beautiful.
You are my successor.
I'd be honored.